tiens là beaucoup de gens ce qui me pose
la question est ce que comme hanouna il
est dans le groupe canal+ il paye pas
canal
hebbadj et brouillard je vous en ai ma
facture de 20 l'an ya personne tout le
monde peut dire même hanouna et ils
payent rubis sur l'ongle
ah mais je vous dis cela n'a pas eu
comme tout le monde et il ferme sa
gueule en les termes sa tronche et a
terminé
et quand je peux vous dire que quand je
paye pas à ça tape à la porte ils
enlèvent l'antenne avec le décor a
changé ce soir fait dire comme ya très
peu ta sont les autorités me regarde le
pen sur son balcon quand j'étais petit
on avait un faux décodeurs avec mon père
j'ai pas peur de venir
je le dis jamais un décodeur volé mon
père avait acheté 500 balles voilà le
mec m'a dit tu payes 500 balles une fois
et à canal+ a toute la vie
eh ben on a payé face au mal une fois on
a eu canal+ s'est passé après ap côtoie
le cas la puce est la plus ce jour avec
mon père et ma mère où ils ramènent le
faux décodeur mon père alors mon père il
se prenait rien faire c'était mesrine
lara défaut décodeur elle a à nouveau
décodeur genre il est rentré à son
mécanisme de suivi
l'été aura été comme âge il est parti à
la tête et il a faim il a fait comme ça
mais tellement au fond n'a été pris en
filature
il a ramené le fou décodeur roberval et
avons perdu
je me rappelle d'un match de foot on se
met tous dans le salon l'avons perd ses
environs ma mère arlette à tajine là
c'est le tas gilles de la victoire
normalement ce tajine tu l'as vu deux
fois quand la france a été championne du
monde en 98 et le jour où mon père a
ramené le fond décodeur canal donc là
bas mais ramène le tajine
on est tous là il est 20 heures 58 et la
ja canal + 14 59 canal+ laquelle elle
plus hélas le match de poule b va la
faire on voit les joueurs rentrés sur la
prime soit pas passé l'acheter ou la
page hôtel j'ai fait des déclarations
d'amour d'humour comme jamais et des
voisins même sortait la fenêtre
s'appelle ange mon père ajoute elle
voilà pour les mets ta héros est là les
joueurs arrivent au centre du terrain
même et là c'est le coup le roi là et là
tu as ton père ouais bon père dont il
regarde tout le monde et voit qu'il est
passé pour en tout cas
et auxerre forcément ils essayent tous
les fils qui servent à rien mon frère il
sait très bien qu'on s'est fait ken mes
dessins alors après mon père il a eu un
truc ici on va mettre des lunettes
d'eramet qui lui a fait croire qu'avec
des lunettes spéciales
sa poubelle ça mais ça pouvait désormais
le truc la classe à projet dit il on
fait des sauts et on s'est retrouvé
toute la famille la mère est la même
celle d'un élan marine le tai-chi prix
goethe à jean arrière je suis on me
jette comme des cons et fera pas sans la
foi
donc moi je te tue ça pendant des années
et tout ce que des mois est dans le
groupe c'est une fierté pour la
[Applaudissements]